[Musique]
au revoir au revoir monsieur Gard
bonjour général trincan merci beaucoup
d'être notre invité ce matin vous êtes
ancien chef de la mission militaire
française auprès de l'ONU auteur de ce
livre ce qui nous attend l'effet
papillon des conflits mondiaux c'est
sorti chez Robert Lafond on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Julien lescuillers La
Voix du Nord bonjour Julien bonjour Ryan
bonjour général on va évidemment parler
de la du conflit au Proche-Orient et
d'abord de la situation et notamment de
ce qui s passé ces dernières heures
général trincan puisque plusieurs
personnes ont été tuées dans la frappe
d'un hôpital à Gaza alors chacun se
rejette la responsabilité le Hamas acus
Israël Israël le Djihad islamique est-ce
qu'on peut savoir qui est responsable
alors d'abord vous avez raison de dire
quelques personnes ont été tuées parce
que on a commencé à 200 puis 500 puis
probablement de demain ça aurait été
2000 ça c'est le premier point moi j'ai
vu les images c'est plutôt un parking à
côté de l'hôpital qui a été touché les
informations qu'on a qui quand même
aujourd'hui se croisent toutes c'est
plutôt un missile qui a été soit détruit
soit qui a raté et qui est retombé et en
retombant il a créé des dégâts voilà
mais ce missile il venait de Gaza il
venait pas d'Israël ça aujourd'hui on a
l'information aation quasiment ouais le
problème c'est que le mal est fait le
mal est fait sur avec deux objectifs le
président Biden arrivé en Israël à ce
moment-là h et devait se réunir à amaman
avec Égypte euh Palestine Jordanie
Israël et lui et c'était l'ouverture
d'une voie politique voie politique qui
n'existe plus depuis des années et donc
c'était la bonne chose à faire
malheureusement elle a été annulée sous
le choc de cette attaque et surtout des
fausses informations qui ont été données
au départ deuxème impact ces fausses
informations écouté dans la rue arabe
sont prises pour argent comptant et donc
la rue arabe se réveille et la rue arabe
ça veut dire les gouvernements des pays
arabes qui eux souhaitaent traité avec
Israël je rapporte les accords d'abaham
et puis les négociations en cours avec
l'Arabie Saoudite ben sont tenus par la
rue d'une certaine façon et ne peuvent
pas le faire donc le mal est fait il n'y
a pas eu la Réunion et il y a une levée
en masse
au profit de la cause palestinienne et
moi je rappelle toujours il faut bien
qu'on sépare le Hamas de la cause
palestinienne le Hamas sont des
terroristes qui ne veulent pas négocier
qui veulent la destruction d'Israël la
Palestine a le droit à un état mais
juste on va en parler mais juste qu'on
comprenne bien est-ce que c'était
volontaire avec cette frappe ou est-ce
que c'est un accident non je pense que
c'était pas volontaire je pense que
c'était un accident et que ça a été
exploité et donc vous considérez que
c'est un tournant dans la guerre C c'est
un peu les mots de Denis Bechard un
exdplomate en jordanier qui disait que
dans tous les cas ça portait un coup
décisif à l'image de l'État d'Israël oui
c'était c'est absolument terrible parce
que depuis le début Israël qui est sous
un choc absolu depuis le 7 octobre est
réuni pour faire quelque chose je dis
bien faire quelque chose alors ça me
rappelle une une expression quand
j'étais aux nations unit en youoslavie
quand le chef disait à New York
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire faites
quelque chose sans dire qu'il fallait
faire donc c'est c'est c'est terrible
d'en arriver là pourut faire quelque
chose parce que le choc est trop
important et aujourd'hui les Américains
et les Européens aussi retiennent un peu
la main d'Israël en disant attention aux
populations civile ne faites pas
n'importe quoi d'où les retards qui ont
eu progressifs avec un ultimatum de 24
heur puis de 48 he puis de 72 he et
l'attaque qui n'a toujours pas eu lieu
et quelle forme prendre l'attaque ça
risque d'être compliqué justement vous
faites bien de de de le dire de le
préciser parce que quel peuvent être les
et les conséquences de cette de ce de ce
drame à l'hôpital de de Gaza sur les
opérations terrestres israéliennes je
pense que ça va être ça va
insister inciter pardon ça va inciter
les Israéliens à être encore plus
prudents parce qu'il voit bien l'effet
déjà produit mais imaginez aujourd'hui
une attaque terrestre euh des chars qui
tire une famille qui est restée dans un
bloc ce qui est possible hein euh on va
montrer les cadavres on va les
multiplier par 10 ou 20 et là l'effet va
être absolument catastrophique mais
juste plus prudent ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'il peut ne pas y avoir
d'opération terrestre ça veut dire
qu'elle sera de moindre envergure ou ça
veut dire qu'elle sera reportée je pense
qu'elle sera de moindre envergure on a
vu euh 400000 hommes rassemblés
l'invasion de Gaza je pense que ça va
être plus des incursions peut-être
fortes et brutales et puis le deuxième
aspect qu' faut mais il y en aura une
pour vous ça c'est inéluctable ben si
vous voulez on peut pas dire on va euh
éradiquer le Hamas ce qui à mon avis est
un faux objectif le véritable objectif
c'est la destruction de l'infrastructure
du Hamas alors on en parlait tout à
l'heure il y a déjà eu des excursions en
2014 mais ça fait 10 ans et depuis 10
ans le Hamas a construit des tas de
tunnels des tas de choses donc il faut
détruire ça oui et comment le faire là
je laisserai la main au généraux
israéliens qui sont en position pour le
faire donc ce que vous nous dites c'est
que selon vous l'État israélien n'est
pas prêt à s'embourber dans dans Gaza je
crois que plus le temps passe plus il se
rend compte après le choc qui en 48 he
fait que on y va on y va s'aperçoit que
c'est compliqué en plus si vous voulez
c'est quand même au grand jour l'échec
total de la politique de netanahou et
donc tous les discours de netanahou très
VAT en guerre au début perd un peu de
crédibilité au f un mesure il est
fragilisé aujourd'hui benamin netaniahou
par ce qui s'est passé bah il est à mon
avis
politiquement mort c'est quand même lui
qui a favorisé le Hamas cornerisé la S
Jordanie qui n'a pas écouté les
informations égyptiennes qui lui
disaient attention il va se passer
quelque chose qui favorisait la
colonisation qui est critiqué par tout
le monde en 6 Jordanie donc c'est un
échec absolu de sa politique qui
débouche sur quoi sur aujourd'hui l'État
vengeur alors que ça devrait être l'état
protecteur et donc c'est une catastrophe
donc je pense que derrière le choc et
moi j'ai j'ai j'ai appelé en en Israël
bien sûr il y a un choc complet ce qu'a
fait le Hamas c'est totalement
inqualifiable mais au bout du compte on
en est arrivé là parce qu'on a favorisé
ces extrémistes pour favoriser nos
extrémistes à nous et donc là la société
israélienne est une société démocratique
il va y avoir des questions réelles qui
vont se poser avec des enquêtes avec et
cetera pour l'instant pour l'instant va
dire que la société israélienne est
favorable à la contre-attaque à la
contre-attaque mais jusqu'à quel point
est-ce que on peut imaginer que la
société se retourne au moment où il
risque d'y avoir des des pertes énormes
dans la bataille dans Gaza alors se
retourne je ne pense pas mais il va y
avoir des bruits qui vont dire bon ça
suffit il y a un moment faut qu'est-ce
que vous avez obtenu bon ça va on s'en
va ou bien faut y aller jusqu'au bout
parce que vous avez pas obtenu donc ça
va être une gestion là on va rentrer
dans l' militaire ça va être une gestion
purement militaire ça va être de dire ok
jusqu'où on va et qu'est-ce qu'on donne
comme preuve que ce qu'on a fait est une
réussite et est prêt l'armée israélienne
est-elle prête à une une offensive
terrestre on sait qu'il se repose
beaucoup sur l'aérien et ça fait
quelques temps vous le disiez vous-même
qu' N sont pas intervenus en milieu
urbain est-ce que ils sont tout
simplement capable de alors ils sont
capables mais je pense avec des
objectifs forcément limités et une
implication limitée dans le temps et une
question qu' va falloir voir aujourd'hui
la résilience de la société israélienne
est fantastique mais admettez que une
unité blindée arrive que
les le Hamas fasse sauter un tunnel sous
cette unité provoque 150 200 morts coupe
une unité et qui a une unité qui soit
prise en étau au sein du dispositif avec
des images fournies par le
Hamas des cadavres des des soldats qui
sont un peu perdus au milieu de truc
vous imaginez ce que ça peut créer en
Israël donc il faut faire le Hamas va
utiliser la communication c'est clair il
va utiliser la capacité de mener une
guerre asymétrique sur un territoire
qu'il connaît parfaitement avec des
moyens qu'il a préparé pour cette guerre
et donc l'état d'Israël va être dans une
enfin tal pardon va être dans une
situation difficile à cela s'ajoute
général une autre difficulté c'est la
présence d'otage dont on connaî pas
exactement le le nombre est-ce que la
main israélienne ne doit pas être plus
légère du fait aussi de la présence de
ces otages écoutez les otages c'est un
sujet extrêmement difficile j'en
discutais avec un ancien patron du Raid
j'en discutais avec des Israéliens des
Israéliens me disaient un truc terrible
il nous disaent pour nous les otages
sont déjà morts on n pas donc ça veut
dire que Israël a fait une croix de su
ilent jamais le dire attendez on va il
faut négocier pour des otages on fait
tout pour les sortir de là mais tout ça
s'arrête à au créneau de négociation
est-ce que le Hamas veut négocier ça
s'arrête à l'information qu'on a est-ce
qu'on a des informations pour aller les
chercher ou pas et à mon sens
aujourd'hui on a ni l'un ni l'autre donc
vous donc ça veut dire que ça va pas
changer la stratégie militaire d'Israël
bah parce que c'est sinon Israël est
obligé de dire bon on y va pas on
négocie ça va durer des mois le Hamas a
gagné le Hamas a gagné il a pourri la
situation Israël n'est pas intervenu
donc les otages c'est vraiment mais
encore une fois le Hamas a monté une
opération qui a réussi horrible mais qui
a réussi qui a fait un choc absolu et
s'est protégé en prenant des otages et
en disant nous on va faire durer les
choses oui tout ça est calculé
évidemment oui et et en continuant juste
avec la la population civile puisque la
hamass refuse l'évacuation demandée par
Israël du nord de Gaza ça veut dire
aussi que le Hamas compte se servir des
civils dans cette guerre et des et pour
contrer la ripose d'israëel bien sûr
bien sûr parce que il y a deux sortes
d'otagees il y a les Israéliens pris en
otage et il y a la population de Gaza
faut rappeler que le Hamas a mis des
blocs a empêché les gens de
partir enfin il voulait pas qu'il partte
maintenant ça a raté puisque les 3/4 on
ditil y a plus d'un million de gens qui
sont partis et Israël maintenant décide
de réapprovisionner en eau en
électricité et de laisser passer les
convoi humanitaire mais dans le sud pour
que tout le monde parte bien dans le sud
et que le terrain soit clair pour l'opé
tion terrestre dont nous parlions mais
dans ce cadre là est-ce que les les
démocraties occidentales la France du
fait de la présence d'otage de double
nationalité au sein de de Gaza ne peut
pas faire pression sur le gouvernement
de netanou
elle peut inciter faire pression c'est
compliqué la France est bien sûr en
soutien d'Israël compte tenu de ce qui
s'est passé le 7 octobre mais comme les
États-Unis elle retient la main de tsal
elle retient la main de netanahou on l'a
bien vu dans la l'intervention entre
netaniaou et et le président baonè
netanahou ne disait plus rien et c'est
les États-Unis c'est là où c'est
extraordinaire je trouve monsieur
netanahou on l'envoie serrer la main des
soldats faire de la com mais la
politique c'est Monsieur Biden qui l'a
fait et puis netanahou netanahou il est
dans l'impossibilité c'est c'est
l'aboutissement
d'année de d'erreur politique et donc
aujourd'hui il peut rien faire si ce
n'est dire on va se venger encore encore
une fois je répète l'état il est fait
pour protéger pas pour venger oui parce
que le Benyamin netanou veut une
victoire totale mais en vérité on ne
sait pas à quoi correspond cette
victoire totale oui ça vous avez
parfaitement raison qu'est-ce que c'est
pour ça que éradiquer le Hamas et le
mauvais terme h casser l'infrastructure
du Hamas ça peut être un objectif puis
casser vous pouvez dire j'ai détruit 25
tunnels j'ai machin je ça
c'est ce qui s'est déjà passé qui n'a au
final rien provoqué oui mais qui peut
affaiblir pendant un moment et le
problème non mais le problème c'est
c'est pour ça que la réunion de Han moi
je je reste sur ma fin parce que vous
affaiblissez le Hamas vous montez la S
Jordanie peut-être pas marmou Abas
peut-être d'autres et à ce moment-là
vous remettez le dossier politique sur
la table et là si vous voulez la rue
arabe qui dit tout le temps le problème
c'est la Palestine et c'est pour ça
qu'ils appuyent le Hamas aujourd'hui et
ben on leur dit ben c'est pas le Hamas
le problème il faut régler ça autrement
et il faut régler le problème de la
Palestine autrement et revenir peut-être
aux accords d'Oslo on va revenir sur le
risque d'embrasement mais du coup ça
serait quoi une victoire totale
qu'est-ce qu' ferait dire à Israël
qu'elle a gagné ce conflit mais il n'y
aura pas de victoire totale du tout il y
aura des victoires partielles qui
pourrai affaiblir le Hamas qui pourrai
punir le Hamas mais le problème c'est
que faut pas en rester là il faut en
revenir à un dossier politique et le
dossier politique de la Palestine doit
être réouvert mais avec quel Inter cur
vous le disiez vousmême Mar dabas le
président de l'Autorité palestinienne
est complètement démonétisé et donc il
n'y a plus personne pour négocier avec
le gouvernement Isra alors vous avez
raison d'autant que beaucoup des gens du
fata par exemple ont été mis en prison
en Israël la question c'est Israël
est-ce qu'elle peut avoir un
interlocuteur qui est en prison et que
mais ça serait un un choc he en disant
ok il faut discuter on peut discuter
avec lui au passage sous la table
pendant qu'il est en prison mais vous
voyez trou trouver trouver des des
éléments de réponse mais c'est c'est
catastrophique cette politique depuis 20
30 ans mais la solution elle se trouve
où est-ce que finalement elle ne se
trouve pas à l'extérieur des frontières
d'Israël dans les mains du président
américain ou ou bien au Qatar en Égypte
alors je pense qu'il y a de deux choses
vous avez raison c'est un peu l'effet
papillon dont je parle dans mon livre il
faut essayer de calmer les choses autour
au Qatar en Arabie Saoudite en Jordanie
en Égypte il faut calmer les choses
revenir à la possibilité de négociation
mais pour ça faut donner quelque chose
donc oui on revient à la Palestine on
revient à la Palestine on revient au
dossier politique de la Palestine et
d'un État palestinien et de
l'autodétermination des Palestiniens le
président Biden l'a dit donc faut donner
ça pour calmer les choses de ce côté-là
en disant ok il y a un problème ponctuel
mais là nous on s'occupe du long terme
et créer et là vous empêcher l'ffet
papillon de la crise et à ce moment-là
vous revenez au règlement
ponctuel de ce qui est en train de se
passer aujourd'hui mais en ayant
désamorcé ce qui se passe ailleurs et
fait papillon qui va bien au-delà de ce
dont nous parlons qui parle de théran
qui parle de Moscou qui parle de péquin
justement qu est quelle est l'influence
de de Moscou sur ce sur ce que sur ce
dossier est-ce qu'ils sont là pour
inflammer encore plus la blessure ou
bien pour essayer de la côériser ils
sont là comme d'habitude pour profiter
de la situation comme ils le font en
Afrique ils profitent de la situation il
peent en profiter c'est une ob pour
Vladimir ptine monsieur Poutine à Pékin
qui est l'ôre d'honneur et cetera et
cetera bon en fait il se rend pas compte
qu'il est il est complètement aotage des
Chinois enfin il se rend sûrement compte
parce qu'il est pas idiot mais il est
complètement au Tage des chinois mais
dans cette affaire là mais est-ce que ça
peut être une auè pour Vladimir Poutin
mais bien sûr c'est une obè il est
l'allié de l'Iran et il peut dire au
monde arabe vous avez vu c'est comme
d'habitude les Israéliens et les
Américains regardez ce qu'ils font et
nous on les défenseurs de la Palestine
et au passage il y a eu deux résolutions
qui ont été présentées au cons sécurité
qui ont été refusé l'une par les Russes
l'autre par les Américains et donc ça
permet vous voyez on n'est pas sur le
même pied vous vous rappelez cette C ce
projet de résolution du Brésil he qui
qui appelait justement à une qui qui qui
rappelit la posuse humanitaire
nécessaire dans la dans la guerre
Washington reprochait simplement au
texte de pas rappeler le le le droit
d'Israël à se défendre est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre à ce que finalement l'ONU
soit
complètement impuissante face à la
situation mais
le Conseil alors je je reprends pas le
Conseil de sécurité de l'enu est
impuissant pour traiter du problème
palestinien à cause de ce que nous
venons d'expliquer c'est-à-dire que les
Américains soutienent mordicus à Israël
au passage j'ai commandé un bataillon au
Liban moi j'ai vu les Israéliens
attaquer au Liban tuer des soldats
Fidjiens sous casque bleu
pas une déclaration de l'ONU contre ça
parce que les Américains le refusai donc
si vous voulez faut en prendre les
Américains ont leur tort d'ailleurs le
président Biden je trouvais très
honnêtement hier a dit après l'attaque
du 11 septembre nous avons commis des
erreurs c'était 2003 et moi je fais un
parallèle de 11 septembre tout le monde
est autour des
États-Unis 2003 le monde est contre les
États-Unis je dis 3/4 du monde dirigé
par la France d'ailleurs à l'époque et
là aujourd'hui le 7 octobre tout le
monde est derrière Israël et là tout le
monde est en train de s'écarter d'Israël
donc il y a un parallèle c'est l'effet
papillon de ces crises qui ont un effet
terrible sur le long terme un mot juste
sur le Liban puisque vous en parlez et
qui Catherine Colona la minist des
Affaires étrangères a de nouveau appelé
à éviter l'escalade à éviter un
embrasement est-ce qu'il y a un risque
d'un nouveau front avec le Liban oui il
y a un risque et ça c'est dans les mains
de Tan parce que le hzbollah il est
vraiment aux ordres de Tan on a envoyé
le Hezbollah combattre en Syrie parce
que tan l'a demandé et
là sera là il est complètement dans les
mains de de téran donc si vous voulez il
y aura pas d'incursion enfin je crois il
y aura pas d'incursion du hzbollah en
Israël mais il y aura des peut-être des
frappes et ça maintient une pression sur
le front nord et de vous comprenez bien
qu'Israël ayant le problème de Gaza à
régler une pression sur le fond Nord
voir du côté du plateau du goulan voire
en 6 Jordanie ça devient une situation
extrêm ça veut dire ça affbl Israël elle
peut elle peut tenir tous ses fronts
l'armée israélienne
écoutez il y a deux porte-avion
américains au large qui sont là pour
essayer de calmer les choses si quand je
dis de porte-avion c'est deux groupe
aéronaval c'est considérable
considérable donc il y a de quoi
empêcher l'escalade mais on est dans une
guerre asymétrique donc je suis pas sûr
que de groupes à uneuron naval ça règle
le problème de frappe dub est-ce qu'on
peut juste éclairer un la la main de de
de de
l'Iran j'ai j'ai cru entendre que
finalement il n'était pas au totalement
au courant de de de l'amplitude de de
l'attaque du du Hamas ils les
soutiennent alors que ils sont chit on
est chite à térant et qu'on soutient un
mouvement fanatique sunnite finalement à
quoi correspond la cette politique
iranienne oui le problème c'est que le
le Hamas qui veut la destruction
d'Israël c'est comme l'Iran donc l'un
est sunite l'autre chiite mais les
ennemis mes ennemis sont mes amis hein
donc c'est comme ça que ça se passe ça
c'est le premier point le deuxème point
vous avez raison on connaît moi je
connais pas la liberté d'action réelle
du Hamas mais il est pas impossible que
le Hamas aidé en permanence par téran
bien sûr et par le Qatar mais par Israël
souvenons-nous que les valiles de billet
transporté du Qatar vers le Hamas
puisque ça passer par Israël avec
l'accord d'Israël
donc ce soutien permanent ça ne veut pas
dire que dans le montage de l'opération
jusqu'au bout le massacre la façon dont
le massacre a été perpétré et cetera
c'est été piloté par téran c'est pas
certain maintenant quand vous soutenez
des gens terroriste comme le Hamas vous
devez vous attendre à des dérapages et
une dernière question Julien et
oui vous disiez euh donc que hormis les
États-Unis sur Israël il difficile
d'imaginer de faire taire les les armes
est-ce que la France peut encore avoir
une une quelconque influence sur Israël
alors dans la situation de crise
aujourd'hui ça me paraît difficile c'est
les Américains Israël terminé moi j'ai
vécu aux États-Unis à New York grande
ville juive là-bas je peux vous dire que
le soutien est absolu
donc je pense que c'est la ligne majeure
le problème c'est qu'on a un petit peu
abandonné la politique lié à la
Palestine en France on a été beaucoup en
soutien d'Israël ce qui me paraît normal
en ce moment mais sur le long terme on
s'est un peu écarté de la politique
traditionnelle arabe Fran française oui
avec cette solution à deux États qui ét
par les présidents précédents on a pu
été tellement une voix là-dessus on
s'est concentré un peu sur le Liban le
président a même donné un envoyé spécial
mais globalement cette politique
peut-être qu'un envoyé spécial eû été
utile mais qui aurait dû travailler dans
la durée c'est le piège de nos
démocraties nos démocraties avec les
élections alors c'est bien parce qu'on a
des élections donc on peut dire ce qu'on
veut et puis on va changer les choses
mais le problème c'est que la continuité
dans la politique et compqu le président
Poutine il a pas de problème il va être
élu au mois de mars il y aura pas
d'alternance vous comprenez alors que
chez nous ben on sait pas ce qui se
passera dans 6 mois merci général
Trincant merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité on remonte votre livre ce
qui nous attend les fait papillon des
conflits mondiaux on le voit c'est sorti
chez Robert Lafond merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité Julien la une
de la voie du Nord rien à voir on parle
de l'immobilier beauoup oui et
aujourd'hui je rappelle aussi à haras la
cérémonie à la cathédrale d'aras en
présence du président de la République
pour le professeur tué et vous faites
bien de le rappeler merci Julien merci
général TR passe au club des territoires